emilien a deux vies comme tous les
apprentis il partage son temps entre le
lycée et l'atelier de l'entreprise à
morteau 14 semaines par an on y enseigne
les maths ou l'histoire de l'art pour
préparer en deux ans un brevet des
métiers d'art en horlogerie ce manuel
que les courses je préfère j'ai préféré
l'apprentissage comme ça il ya semaine
de boulot semaine d'école il ya moins
deux semaines d'école en fait après un
ca paix de carrosserie qu'il a
définitivement convaincu qu'il avait
fait fausse route
emilien a rejoint l'atelier d'horlogerie
démontrèrent belin qui accueille
régulièrement des apprentis façon
d'entrer dans le monde des adultes
c'est totalement différent que
monde adolescent depuis quelques mois
emilien est au service après vente de
l'entreprise l'atelier le plus exigeant
sans doute celui justement dirigé par
son maître d'apprentissage qui se trouve
être aussi son père avait monté hier du
moment qu'il franchit la porte du sav
après ça reste une personne comme les
autres faut pas faire de différence
vis-à-vis de moi vous avez bien d'autres
personnages un apprenti qui par
définition est là pour se former
d'abord au calibre les plus simples puis
au mouvement mécanique plus sophistiqués
qu'il devra connaître pour obtenir son
diplôme une formation au long cours
s'assoit contrat il sera un moment de
panique répit de 24
je suis en train de poser la mise à
l'air le temps si j'ai besoin de deux
heures pour apprendre à faire ça je
prendrais ne leur sied pas de pression
je sais pas il n'y a pas de pression
un apprenti qui arrive on va les guider
des pièces qui sont pas faites pour la
fabrication qui sont faites vraiment que
pour les affranchis ils vont s'exercer
dessus et seulement quand on verra qui
sont aptes à réparer un moment on le
remettra des mouvements de fabrication
au bout de six mois qu'il commence à
être opérationnels donc ils commencent à
pouvoir travailler sur des produits
finis donc ça c'est déjà c'est déjà
quelque chose de très positif
un investissement soutenu en partie par
les pouvoirs publics mais aussi une
volonté de l'entreprise
ça nous tient à coeur de transmettre ce
que notre savoir puisque on n'a pas
envie qu'il se perde
et puis le troisième on peut relier un
troisième retour c'est
c'est par exemple ce qu'il décide de
rester chez nous un pari sur l'avenir
pas toujours récompensés car 70% des
apprentis formés en france passent la
frontière à l'issue de leur formation
emilien lui est moins catégorique et
espère intégrer l'entreprise g20 attend
maintenant l'école ça va jamais été trop
mon truc
du coup travailler plus et cette fois il
ne doute plus il sera horloger après son
changement d'orientation s'est une
nouvelle fois l'apprentissage qui lui
aura permis d'être sûr de son choix
k